[Music]
pirate our conference is a confession
for a pilot hours to meet up I should
this year we've got a third edition our
conference gathering data scientist must
learn as all people that are working
with data so it's gonna be very very
interesting even for knowledge sharing
and networking they had talked about the
ethics of artificial intelligence
I gave several examples and in my
opinion one of the most important ones
was really biased this was one of the
main points of my talk as really biased
the AI systems have unfortunately
possibility to really increase bias in
our societies by automatize advisor
[Music]
my talk today was about the trusted AI
and I'm really happy that the economy
and the ecosystem really changed because
two years ago it was all a mess and now
each and every company cloud provider
and partitioner is talking about tested
AI and released some open-source tooling
for it and I just explained how this
works and can be used my father I
basically shared some ideas some
experience how you can do transfer
learning in an attempt if active manner
and how you can actually bridge the gap
more between research and industry using
this language modes like Bert for your
practical use cases also it's pretty
easy these days to use them so there's
plenty of open source code all shared in
the presentation
there is nice that in particle physics
was that I really want to know how the
universe works and they turns out that
artificial intelligence really speaks to
that
because it's it's all about
understanding how the universe our well
at least how the world works and if you
think about it AI is really making an
impact not only on our lives but the
whole world and that's also what I'm
going to be speaking about at this
conference and I really look forward to
that I specifically came to versal
because it's more focused on data
science or analytics stuff that I'm much
more interested in and I'm super excited
I'm the keynote was wonderful there's a
lot of topics like especially related to
NLP that's going on and I'm super
excited for the next two days
[Music]